Oda just revealed one of the biggest
mysteries in one piece and this changes
everything after five years of waiting
and speculating we got to see the true
nature of imusama's power and this could
be the strongest devil fruit in all of
One Piece emu's devil fruit is the dark
counterpart of Luffy's Nika fruit the
anti-nika fruit whose power may be
Luffy's single greatest weakness in this
video I will tell you why this devil
fruit could be the Luffy killer so let's
get into it you guys know the drill if
you enjoy our one piece content and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment right now it only
takes you a second but it helps me out a
lot and if you watch my videos but you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a big favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications finally this video will
contain all the most recent one-piece
manga spoilers so please please proceed
with caution you have been warned
imusama is a mysterious being who was
first introduced in chapter 906 of the
manga which happened about five years
ago and 20 years after the manga started
imusama's introduction immediately
shocked the entire one-piece fan base as
it revealed that this being is the true
ruler of the world government the one
who sits on the empty throne and the one
to whom even the Goro say must bow down
to nobody besides the very upper echelon
of the world government is even aware of
imusama's existence and yet this being
is the one who really decides what the
world government does and doesn't do and
who or what will be erased from history
interestingly enough imusama is the de
facto king of the world which is the
very title That Rocks the zebeg had set
out to attain some four decades ago this
and other aspects of emu's character
have led to insane amounts of
speculation and Theory crafting among
the fan base but thankfully after 180
chapters of wondering we are finally
getting answers up till now little was
known about imusama's personality other
than the fact that he or she enjoys
casual strolls through the garden and
playing with butterflies oh and
destroying entire Islands in a matter of
seconds we also know that this being has
taken a special interest in four
individuals Luffy Blackbeard shirahoshi
and Vivi in fact we did have a small
hint that emu is interested in Vivi even
more so than the others or at least in a
different way from the other three
that's because vivi's photo is the only
one that wasn't partially destroyed by
emu the other three were either pierced
with a saber or torn into pieces and
left on the ground in the Garden of
Flowers but for whatever reason vivi's
photo wasn't damaged and imusama takes
the photo with him or her upon leaving
the garden imusama used a saber which is
a specific type of sword in order to
pierce through a photo of shirahoshi
this is interesting because a number of
very important characters have been
shown to use Sabers in the story
including Shanks Roger and of course
zabek as we know Blackbeard even named
his ship the saber of zebik so this
saber connection could be more than just
a coincidence emu is introduced during
the revery Arc but it is over 150
chapters later that we learned what
really happened at the reverie we
learned earlier that the king of
alabaster nefertari Cobra wanted to have
a special audience with the gorosei and
this audience was granted to him on the
fourth day of the Reverend Cobra entered
the chamber that houses the empty Throne
on his own and there he met with the
five Elders Cobra wanted to talk about
the void century and the establishment
of the world government 800 years ago
more specifically he wanted to talk
about his ancestor nefertari Lily the
woman who was Queen of alabasta at the
time that the world government was
formed formed we've known for a while
that the world government was founded by
20 Allied kingdoms and that the ruling
families of these kingdoms moved to
marijua to become the celestial dragons
the gods of the new world these royal
families were then replaced by other
royal families who went on to rule their
respective Nations but we've always been
led to believe that one of the families
the nefertari family refused to move to
marijua and that is why they continue to
rule over alabasta to this day in fact
the celestial dragons consider this
decision to be a betrayal but for
whatever reason they decided to put up
with it and alabaster remained firmly
within the fold of the world government
while the nefertari family continued to
rule the country for centuries but as
Cobra figured out there's a problem with
this story even though the former queen
of alabasta nefertari Lily was supposed
to have left marijua and returned to
alabasta she never actually made it back
in fact fact she completely disappeared
from history and her place as ruler of
alabasta was taken by her younger
brother so yes the nefertari family did
continue to rule the country but not
through Lily Lily disappeared as if she
had been deliberately erased from
history you know the very thing that emu
has a habit of doing to both people and
places when Cobra asks the five Elders
what happened to Lily and they simply
say that they don't know according to
the records Lily did not agree to become
a Celestial Dragon and she did not
pledge her sword to the empty Throne
that is why there are only 19 swords
around the throne itself instead of 20.
but the specifics have been lost to the
cobwebs of history and so the gorose
simply assumed that Lily went home Cobra
then follows up by asking what is the D
all five Elders are shocked by this
question and they ask Cobra why he would
ask such a thing Cobra reveals that
although Lily never came back to
Alabaster she did leave a brief 800 year
old letter behind this letter has been
passed on from ruler to ruler within the
nefertari family from the time of the
Void century and it is because of the
contents of this letter that Cobra is
asking about the initial D and as this
conversation is happening within Cobra
and the gorosei inside the throne room
something truly shocking occurs imusama
walks into the room surprising everyone
the corose warn emu that Cobra is still
there and of course no one is supposed
to see emu besides them but emu doesn't
seem to care imusama speaks the word
Lily then walks up to the empty throne
and sits on top of it Cobra is stunned
because he knows that no one is supposed
to sit on that Throne no one is supposed
to have the power to control the whole
world and yet emu is right there and
this mysterious being addresses Cobra
directly emu says the following mu shall
address two of the points being
discussed and thou must answer a single
question in return Cobra and just from
this single sentence we can already
figure out a bunch of information first
of all emu talks in the third person and
uses the unique first person pronoun mu
it is clear that emu talks in an
Antiquated way which indicates that this
creature is extremely old in fact Cobra
basically confirms this as he says that
he's heard the name emu before one of
the original 20 rulers of the world
government was also called IMU which
implies that this emu has been alive for
800 years this seems to confirm the
popular fan theory that emu is Immortal
and has been around since the creation
of the world government some 8 centuries
ago most likely because he or she he was
granted immortality by a previous user
of the op up fruit if true this is of
course absolutely huge because it would
mean that we have a living witness to
everything that happened during the
ancient war and this puts us that much
closer to finally learning the full
truth about the void Century emu refuses
to confirm or deny Cobra's speculation
about whether this is the same emu who
helped create the world government
instead emu remains focused on the
initial question that Cobra raised emu
says D is the moniker of our ancient
enemy in recent times it has cropped up
more frequently however it is nothing
but a faint Echo those who carry the
name do not even know of its true
meaning this seems to confirm the
information that we've already gotten in
the past we know that the d-clan are
considered to be enemies of the Gods I.E
enemies of the celestial dragons and we
know that modern clan members like Luffy
don't seem to know what the D really
means or represents nevertheless even
though emu tries to downplay its
importance it is clear that the D is
deeply Troublesome for the world
government emu says that all of this is
Lily's fault without Lily's blunder
Pirates would not be chasing the
poneglyphs and those vexing relics never
would have been scattered all over the
world it seems that Lily nefertari made
some kind of mistake that allowed the
release of the pornoglyphs and so
instead of them being hidden under the
strict control of the world government
they were released into the world where
they could be red and that information
could then presumably be used against
the world government Ebu calls this the
worst possible outcome for the world
government so much so that emu questions
whether losing control of the poneglyphs
was truly a mistake or whether it was
all part of some larger deliberate and
premeditated plan emu seems to suspect
Lily of having been a traitor to the
world government someone who pretended
to be one of the 20 founding members but
was secretly scheming to bring the
government down in the future by
releasing the pornoglyphs out into the
world for others to find the information
on these pornoglyphs clearly represents
an existential threat to the world
government so deliberately releasing
them into the world is essentially an
acknowledgment that your real plan is to
bring the world government down it seems
that Lily tried to play this off as some
sort of mistake or accident but emu
isn't buying it and in order to confirm
the suspicions emu demands to know what
was in Lily's letter more specifically
how did Lily sign the letter was it
simply as Queen Lily of the house
nefertari or was there something else in
her name
Cobra who now realizes that he will
never be able to leave this room alive
no matter what he says decides to just
tell the truth the letter written by
alabast as ancient ruler was signed by
Queen nefertari D lily as soon as emu
hears the word or I guess the letter d a
large sharp aero-shaped tail rushes
towards Cobra and pierces through him as
we know the flame Emperor Sabo has been
secretly listening in on this entire
conversation from afar and when he
realizes that Cobra is being attacked he
jumps in to try to protect him he grabs
Cobra and launches a powerful fire blast
at the throne where emu is located emu
instantly transforms into some sort of
Beast that simply opens its gigantic
mouth and swallows sabo's Flames like
they were nothing and if that wasn't
wild enough in the very next moment the
gorosei also transformed into five
monstrous creatures we only see the them
in silhouette because our boy Oda
freaking loves Silhouettes but it is
clear that one of these creatures is
some sort of giant bird another one has
a bull-like horns and in general they
look like they're using some sort of
Zone devil fruits to take on beastly
forms
Sabo tries to save Cobra by carrying him
out of the throne room and escaping but
Cobra tells him that he'll only be dead
wait Sabo won't be able to get away if
he has to carry Cobra on his shoulders
so Cobra tells Sabo to tell Vivian Luffy
that the nefertari family are also
members of the D Clan this request
reminds Sabo of his childhood and a time
when he Luffy and Ace were discussing
the fact that both Ace and Luffy have
the initial D in their names in fact as
kids luffian Ace said that Sabo could
also have a D in his name he could
become sadibo this little flashback
might actually be more important than
you realize but more on that later as
that Black Arrow tale thing and the
other monsters all attack Sabo and Cobra
again Cobra chooses to sacrifice himself
so that Sabo can escape before he dies
Cobra tells Sabo what Lily's letter said
the pawn lives must be protected fly the
flag that Heralds the world's eventual
Dawn Sabo then escapes and so does
Walpole who by the way has been spying
through a hole in the wall this whole
time he apparently heard and saw
everything just like Sabo since Sabo
found out about emu and then escaped emu
decided that he knows too much and that
he must be erased from history when a
call that Sabo makes to the
revolutionaries is traced to the kingdom
of La Lucia emu uses an incredible
weapon to destroy the entire island of
Lucia in a matter of seconds in order to
ensure that Sabal can't reveal emu's
existence to the revolutionaries this
weapon which looks like a Giant floating
sphere that shoots energy beams down at
the ground seems to have been built by
vegapunk himself possibly inspired by
the ancient weapon nevertheless Sabo
anticipated that this would happen and
so he wasn't actually in La Lucia Sabo
then managed to link up with the
revolutionaries once again and he
brought the refugees from Lucia along
with him and so the stage is set for The
Ultimate Showdown the revolutionaries
now know who really controls the world
government and that information is about
to upend the entire world government
system and change the world as we know
it multiple kingdoms have already
rebelled against the world government
and joined the revolutionaries and their
plan is clear during the reverie they
managed to destroy a huge amount of food
reserves that the celestial dragons had
stockpiled in marijua and the
revolutionaries are now trying to
blockade marijua in order to ensure that
more food and other resources cannot get
there safely the revolutionaries want to
essentially besiege and starve out the
celestial dragons this is an excellent
strategy if they can make it happen
because this strategy uses marijua's
greatest strength and turns it into its
greatest weakness marijua is incredibly
isolated location Atop The Red Line
makes it perhaps the most fortified
place in the world and so it is
incredibly difficult to attack directly
sure you can sneak in some infiltrators
during a big busy event like the reverie
but an entire Army trying to attack such
a well fortified position would be
destroyed easily and yet this remote
location makes it difficult to resupply
the celestial dragons especially if a
revolutionary Army can effectively
blockade the access points and that is
exactly what the revolutionaries are
planning to do as the final Conflict in
one piece heats up and all this talk
about rebellion and Revolution brings us
back to the d-clan who are for some
reason considered to be the ancient
enemies of the celestial dragons as emu
pointed out even the people who have the
D initials in their name today are
unaware of the initial's true meaning
but clearly there is a meaning and
clearly this meaning is extremely
important to EMU and the gorosei
literally the only thing that emu wanted
from Cobra was to confirm that Lily's
signature in that letter included the
initial D as soon as this detail was
confirmed Cobra was attacked and soon
after he was killed so why is the D so
important and why did emu need Cobra to
confirm whether Lily had it in her name
there are of course tons of theories
about the d-clan but a popular one has
been the idea that the d-clan is some
sort of Royal bloodline that was
opposing the world government during the
ancient war so maybe the modern carriers
of this D initial are direct descendants
of the royal Dynasty that the celestial
dragons overthrew and replaced during
the ancient war this would make the
decline natural enemies of the celestial
dragons because they have a claim to the
throne they can claim to be the rightful
rulers of the world and this could lead
the people to support the d-clan and
rebel against the current system one
issue with this Royal bloodline theory
is that the d-clan members don't seem to
be related to each other they seem to be
dispersed all over the world and while
many of them are humans some of them
like Saul are giants so are they really
all related I guess after 800 years they
could all be distantly related and
they're just not aware of it but there
is another possibility
that brief Sauble flashback that I
talked about earlier might be a big clue
about the true nature of the D Clan what
if the D is not directly related to
Bloodlines but rather to allegiances I
mean of course in the present time it is
passed down from generation to
generation kind of like a last name so
we have Monkey D GARP Monkey D dragon
and Monkey D Luffy but perhaps
originally those who had the initial D
in their name chose to take it willingly
as a sign of their dedication to a cause
this cause being their determination to
overthrow the world government and the
celestial dragons and Usher in a new
dawn of the world with the D referring
directly to this Dawn so if you have the
initial D it is because you yourself
chose to adopt it as a way of pledging
allegiance to the dawn which means that
anyone can become a member of the D Clan
as long as they share this Allegiance in
that sense when Luffy and Ace told Sabo
that he could become saw the bow it was
more than just a childish offer although
they didn't know it this was actually a
clue about the true nature of the D Clan
this would explain why emu was so
interested in knowing how exactly Lily
signed that letter as one of the 20
Founders emu likely knew Lily very well
and Lily was clearly trusted with some
important tasks within the world
government which is why she seems to
have had control of the pornoglyphs
after all emu says that Lily's quote
unquote mistake is what allowed for the
pornographs to be Unleashed upon the
world although emu suspects that it may
not have been a mistake at all this
suspicion is finally confirmed after 800
years when Cobra reveals that Lily
signed her name as Queen nefertari D
Lily but why would emu need to get this
information from Cobra emu like knew
Lily personally emu was there when
everything went down so why did it take
800 years for emu's suspicions to
finally be confirmed if Lily's full name
contained the D initial wouldn't someone
like emu with all the resources in the
world at his disposal be able to confirm
this much earlier maybe the D is not
really part of Lily's name at least not
in like a technical or legal sense
because of that the D in Lily's name is
not information you can confirm by
looking into the historical record
that's because Lily added the D to her
name as a way of expressing her
allegiance to Joy boy and the forces
fighting against the world government
she did it secretly only in the most
private letters such as the one Cobra
saw and emu needed the confirmation from
cobra in order to know for sure so while
today the D Clan families passed the D
initial from generation to generation
the original way of obtaining that
initial was not by being born into it
you become a d when you willingly decide
to risk your life to fight against the
world government and to fight for the
ideals represented by Joy boy and the
ancient Kingdom the D initial is itself
kind of like a flag that you hoist
within your name a flag that symbolizes
the new dawn of the world now of course
I I'm not the first person to propose
this Theory it has been around for a
while but after the most recent big
reveals about emu and what happened at
the reverie this theory is beginning to
make a lot more sense my guess is that
the D Clan the dawn of the world Joy boy
and the lyrics of being sake will all
turn out to be closely related for 800
years those who have vowed to fight the
world government have waited for the new
dawn they've been holding on through the
long night but now finally the morning
sun will rise but before that happens
Luffy and all those who are fighting for
a new dawn will have to face off against
emu and the gorosei and the reveal of
emu's true power could tell us a lot
about what is about to happen next we
now know the truth about Luffy's gear 5.
I revealed that absolutely shocked the
fandom last year gear 5 is the awakened
form of the devil fruit we once knew as
the gomugomunomi but whose true name is
the hitohitonomi model Nika the
gomugomonomi was once believed to be a
parmesia type devil fruit that gives its
users body the property of rubber but
the Nika devil fruit turned out to be a
mythical Zone type human human fruit
this devil fruit is named after the sun
god Mika a legendary mythical figure who
is also known as The Warrior of
Liberation and who is believed to bring
freedom and joy to everyone around him
for this reason he is especially revered
by those who are suffering and those who
are oppressed gear 5 or the awakened
form of Nika makes the user's body even
stronger and it also drastically
increases the user's speed and
durability on top of that the user is
now able to transform not only his own
body but also his very surroundings
which is similar to some of the
paramecia Awakenings that we've seen
before but gear 5 goes one step further
because it essentially turns the
outlandish Powers exhibited by
characters in rubber holes animation
into reality gear 5 straight up blurs
the line between the realistic and the
Fantastical by allowing Luffy to become
a Looney Tunes character the awakened
Nika allows its user the freedom to
fight in any way that he pleases and
this devil fruit's power is able to
unleash the power of imagination itself
it has been referred to as the most
ridiculous power in the world so
ridiculous in fact that its user can
instantly gigantify any part of his body
or even his entire body he can make an
opponent's attack bounce off the ground
itself and back at the opponent and he
can grab hold of intangible objects like
lightning and use them as a weapon and
that's still just a small fraction of
Nika's utterly cartoonish and we reality
defying Powers knowing all of this about
the Nika devil fruit my first reaction
to the big reveal of emu's powers in
chapter 1085 was that we may have just
been introduced to the dark counterpart
of Luffy's Nika devil fruit the
anti-nika devil fruit
I mean think about it just like the Nika
fruit emu's power gives its user the
ability to instantly turn into a giant
cartoonish creature a creature that can
perform such outlandish Feats like
manifesting a giant mouth and swallowing
sabo's overpowered flame attack without
taking on any damage emu also appears to
control a long black arrow that can be
used to attack and Pierce through his
opponent from a distance but this Arrow
may not be an arrow at all it may be an
arrow-shaped tale like the ones the
devils are often depicted as having in
cartoons and while both Luffy's and
emu's Powers allow them to instantly
transform into cartoonish creatures and
perform Fantastical Feats that shouldn't
even be possible in the real world the
two Powers also appear to be the perfect
counterparts of each other Luffy's
Awakening turns his hair and much of his
clothing white he becomes a creature
known as the Sun God and he is said to
bring freedom and joy to everyone around
him on the other hand emu is just an old
black and his devil fruit power turns
him into a dark monster while troyboi is
a warrior of Liberation who brings
laughter and joy and who promises to
reveal the truth of the world and
liberate everyone from oppression emu is
the one who oppresses the world from the
Shadows hides the truth in darkness
erases history and uses fear and
violence to force everyone to conform to
his rule in short emu is as close as it
gets to the exact opposite of the
warrior of Liberation emu is the dark
counterpart of Luffy and his devil fruit
is the anti-nika if Luffy is a warrior
of light and freedom emu is the
embodiment of darkness and tyranny if
Luffy is the Sun God then emu is the
Knight devil as I was working on this
video I saw a video by Artur from the
library of O'Hara and in that video he
raised some of the same points as I'm
raising now now so I just wanted to
shout him out real quick I've said this
before but our tour and teching are
channels that you absolutely must
subscribe to if you're a one-piece fan
on YouTube one thing that occurred to me
and that our tour also mentioned was the
fact that if emu's devil fruit is some
sort of dark counterpart to Nika then
maybe this can give us some idea of what
kind of powers emu actually possesses if
Joy Boy AKA Nika has the power to turn
imagination into reality and essentially
make dreams come true then maybe emu's
anti-nika power is to bring the worst
fears and nightmares of people into
reality Nika brings light and laughter
emu brings darkness and silence Nika
brings joy and freedom emu brings Terror
and tyranny Nika brings truth and
Justice emu brings censorship and
control Luffy is trying to become the
pirate king and Achieve his dream and
emu will try to stop him by becoming his
worst nightmare just imagine the ability
to bring into reality the most
over-the-top cartoonish fears and
Nightmares and then use them against
your opponent just imagine Luffy's power
of imagination versus emu's Power of
nightmares colliding in what looks like
a chaotic Tom and Jerry episode on
steroids Sun versus Darkness God versus
devil Truth versus lies Joy versus
Terror and in fact emu's devil fruit
could be Luffy's greatest weakness if
emu's devil fruit has the ability to
bring nightmares and fears into reality
and maybe create illusions that would
exploit someone's greatest fears then we
all know what emu is going to do to
Luffy Luffy's greatest vulnerability is
that he cares deeply for his friends and
that he would do anything to protect
them he would take any risk and make any
sacrifice in order to protect his nakama
so if emu can create illusions that make
Luffy think that his friends are in
life-threatening danger or maybe even
that his friends are already dead this
could lead Luffy to lose it slip up and
play right into emu's hands I can
definitely see something like this
happening in the final battle between
the sun god and the night devil
obviously it's still hard to know what
the true nature of emu's devil power is
but this idea that emu has the anti-nika
fruit and that he is the night devil to
Luffy's son God would make for an
absolutely phenomenal final showdown
maybe emu's devil fruit really is a
special mythical Zone just like Luffy's
Nika fruit but emu's model is the
opposite of a god emu's model is the
hitohito no me model devil
the devil devil fruit what do you guys
think what is emu's true devil fruit
power and could he have the dark
counterpart to Luffy's Nika fruit the
anti-nika devil fruit what about the
gorose what do you think there devil
fruit powers are and how do they work
will we ever see sun god Luffy battle
Knight devil emu directly let me know
down below if you're looking for an epic
one piece video to watch next check out
our video ranking every Straw Hat member
from weakest the strongest Link in the
description and on screen if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more one
piece content in the future leave a
quick like right now and if you're new
to anime Pro or maybe you watch my
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a big favor
and make this the video you subscribe
and hit that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications